happy weekend everybody today I'm taking
you to the Canadian National Exhibition
with Nina she just wanted to get in
[Music]
so the Canadian National Exhibition
otherwise known as a CME is a annual
kind of street carnival here in Toronto
one of our biggest events of the end of
summer to kind of close out the summer
they have rides they have shows and why
we're really going is they have all
sorts of crazy special food and so
Hayden's gonna want to go on the rides
Nina's gonna want to try all the crazy
food and I'm just tagging along for the
ride and you guys are - first stop is
the bathroom because Hayden needs to go
hey Hayden really needs to go to the
bathroom so that's what we're going to
go all right well that's kind of true
[Music]
so then we find it easlick cousins
Jeffrey and Stephanie how was the ride
[Music]
[Music]
was it
hungry and want to try that new food so
things going to take the kids on the
rides with their sister-in-law
now I'm going to get something
so I'm gonna try some of these spaghetti
Dona balls tomato sauce and Parmesan it
was talked about on various blogs here
in Toronto so we're gonna give it a shot
see a face not bad actually pretty
filling I think I'm gonna eat one save
one for Nina cuz she loves trying new
food I didn't really get much because I
wanted to enjoy the food with you
because there's lots of options you want
to try something so I got a spaghetti
ball donut it's a fried spaghetti booth
they also have cinnamon and sugar and
whipped cream version but I got the
tomato sauce yeah
you're not hungry anymore it's pretty
feeling actually but there's lots of
unique stuff in there that we're gonna
have to go in and you're gonna want to
go nuts and try all right let's keep
going
[Music]
baby how was it
good okay get some food guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so scared or when hatin not just starts
to drive because I kind of feel like
that's how is gonna drive all the time
it's very scary I also learned that Nina
is a crazy driver
that is also how she drives in real life
so if you see Nina on the road behind
you go the other way I'm gonna try the
Canadian bacon pickleball
you only live once right let's see how
it is here they are the baking pickle
balls they say to put ketchup or mustard
on I don't know let's go with some
kitchen
[Music]
bacon pickle where's the pickle ah
there's the pickle how is it you like it
really
actually really good suppose that wisely
it's really good I like it Canadian
bacon pickleball yeah why are you
walking so funny
I see a root beer stand
I love root beer you gotta get me some
root beer
[Music]
someone got away I was it
[Music]
you pulled your one you pulled your
muscle Nina's wet
I wasn't a them dancing
[Music]
were you scared
oh yes yeah
[Music]
Jada's having the purple ice cream how
is it mr. yeah
Mina's having come out yet
there it is charcoal
how is it like
other corners not let me give it a try
this black charcoal ice-cream has been
the craze of Toronto in other blogs
everybody's talking about it
pretty good just kind of just kind of
tastes like it's gonna taste like
vanilla it's just vanilla it's just
black vanilla people freak out of our
minor things but still very yummy
vanilla what the farm let's go to the
farm just getting ready for the corn
maze don't get lost
don't die in there don't get lost we'll
see we're going in the corn maze
Hayden's gonna lead us with Jeffrey here
we go guys all right let's not get lost
hey slow down
[Music]
[Music]
you know you guys only solved it so
quickly because I was with you
[Music]
Lena's in line for the Japanese sweet
food all right so we got the kids pizza
hello Hayden's really excited about his
pizza and Nina got us some Japanese
first gotta feed the kids
right look at that energy ready any kids
ready for your pizza oh okay go take it
grab a slice got a plate here comes Nina
it's very excited yes where's Debra
Debra grab some pizza let's go okay Nina
let's see what you ordered I have one of
those too right
okay cheese chicken and beef
Japanese Street food last time right
Natick barely use it and worth the wait
kind of different different it's good he
likes trying different food all right
I'm gonna eat mine Hayden's trying to
bite oh oh and how is it Danny
the bread is like potato you have a
message no message just a big smile all
right all right
the Sun is setting we gotta take this
guy home thank you guys for joining us
on our date it's gonna be a regular
thing that chip does he me and then you
want you to see me maybe Hayden has a
message believe that's a good one I like
that message do you feel like it was
stolen for somebody so the guys who
joining us Nina has a message enjoy your
last few days of summer there you go
thank you guys for watching
[Applause]